I really do love video games and comic
books that's absolutely true so you can
imagine what a big thrill it was for me
to go to this year's New York City's
Comic Con where I actually got to meet
some of these characters in person don't
tell me they're not real I don't want to
hear that let's check it out like you're
out there what what is this
I'm Super Grover soup yes I've never met
you
no but I've played this game have you so
I see you and I get excited and isn't
that how the world should be exactly how
the world should be let me guess what
you are prints on his way into the
bathroom after an orgy two O's in an X
and a smile man are you scary eyes
beetles here what are you sexy asian
cops
we are and Panty and Stocking got a name
this just went from zero to
uncomfortable yeah if I conduct this
interview I'm gonna have to announce it
to my neighborhood yes yes hello
can't talk for you know money reasons I
can't sing any Daft Punk songs but I can
sing a song that sounds like it might be
that fun there's a lot of pretty girls
walking around people dressed up sexy
scantily clad hot role-playing there's
sex in the air how horny are you I mean
I'm a gentleman I try to be I'm just an
eight or a nine
fair enough like eleven I mean I'm at
comic-con is that how it works
Oh twelve I'm very horny
[Applause]
this is the best I feel like I've peaked
under my bed and there's a magical world
why is comic-con the greatest just so
many people here just so excited about
what they love let me believe it I just
met my Robin no you're twins that's
awesome this is your son this is your
son that's real parenting swirly swirly
and now you can just talk normal
I'm fine hey it's weird to me
[Applause]
[Music]